>> HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE WHEN
THEY DO SOMETHING WRONG, TEACH
THEM WHAT IT MEANS TO TREAT
PEOPLE WITH EMPATHY AND RESPECT.
TEACH THEM WHAT NECESSARY
FORCES.
TEACH IN THAT DEADLY FORCE
SHOULD BE USED RARELY AND ONLY
WHEN LIFE IS AT RISK.
>> WITH ANY PROFESSION, THERE
ARE OFFICERS WHO AREN’T SUITED
FOR THE JOB.
SOME CAUSE TROUBLE.
SOMETIMES WORSE.
IN MY EXPERIENCE, IT’S RARE AND
BECOMING RARER.
>> Bret: THAT HIS TESTIMONY ON
CAPITOL HILL TODAY.
WE HAVE SOME BREAKING NEWS
TONIGHT.
FOX NEWS HAS CONFIRMED 1 OF 4
FIRED MINNEAPOLIS POLICE
OFFICERS CHARGED IN THE DEATH OF
GEORGE FLOYD HAS POSTED BAIL.
THOMAS LANE WAS RELEASED FROM
JAIL THIS AFTERNOON AFTER BEING
LOCKED UP FOR ABOUT A WEEK.
LANE HAD BEEN HELD IN LIEU OF A
$750,000 CASH BAIL.
LET’S BRING IN THE PANEL AND
TALK ABOUT POLICE REFORM IN
WHAT’S HAPPENING AND WHAT’S NOT.
CHARLES HURT, OPINION EDITOR FOR
"THE WASHINGTON TIMES."
FORMER TENNESSEE COMMERCE AND
HAROLD FORD JR., CURRENTLY, AND
MATTHEW CONTINETTI, FOUNDING
EDITOR OF "THE WASHINGTON
FREE BEACON."
CHARLIE, THE PRESIDENT SAYS HE’S
COMING OUT WITH SOME REFORMS, A
LIST OF REFORMS.
TESTIMONY TODAY REALLY DEALT
WITH A LOT OF DIFFERENT FACTORS.
IS THERE SOME BIPARTISAN
SOLUTION?
>> I THINK THERE CERTAINLY ARE.
OBVIOUS TO THE DEVIL IS IN THE
DETAILS BUT THAT TESTIMONY FROM
MR. FLOYD’S BROTHER I THOUGHT
WAS A REMARKABLE, IT WAS VERY
POWERFUL.
IT WAS A REMINDER THAT THE
THINGS THAT HE TALKED ABOUT ARE
THINGS THAT I THINK JUST ABOUT
EVERYBODY, CERTAINLY EVERY
POLITICIAN THAT TALKED ABOUT ANY
OF THIS STUFF IN AMERICA TODAY
WOULD AGREE WITH.
WHEN HE TALKED ABOUT THE THINGS
THAT NEEDED TO BE DONE, SUCH AS
BETTER TRAINING FOR POLICE
OFFICERS AND TEACHING, AND
REINFORCING THE FACT THAT DEADLY
FORCE MUST BE RARE AND ONLY WHEN
LIFE IS AT STAKE.
THAT’S A FAR CRY FROM SOME OF
THE CRAZIER THINGS WE ARE
HEARING SOME PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
ABOUT DEFUNDING POLICE
DEPARTMENT SOME THINGS LIKE THAT
THAT.
I WISH THAT THE PEACEFUL
PROTESTERS AND THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, EVERYBODY
WOULD JUST TURN TO MR. FLOYD’S
BROTHER AND LISTEN TO HIM,
BECAUSE WHAT HE’S TALKING ABOUT
RIGHT THERE HAS SUPPORT FROM 99%
OF AMERICANS AND IT’S PROBABLY A
VERY WISE WAY TO GO FORWARD FROM
HERE.
>> Bret: ALL RIGHT, HERE’S THE
PRESIDENT TODAY MEETING IN THE
CABINET ROOM WITH WITH SOME
AFRICAN-AMERICAN LEADERS.
>> YOU GO DOWN A LIST OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM AND ALL
THE THINGS WE’VE DONE,
OPPORTUNITY ZONES, THE BEST
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IN THE HISTORY
JUST BEFORE THE PLAGUE CAME IN.
IT’S GOING TO BE BACK AGAIN SOON
BUT YOU LOOK AT ALL THE THINGS
WE’VE DONE.
WE WORKED ON PRISON REFORM, SO
IMPORTANT.
SO MANY OF THE THINGS.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
ECONOMICS, WHEN YOU LOOK AT HOW
WELL THE BLACK COMMUNITY HAS
BEEN DOING UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION, NOBODY’S DONE
ANYTHING LIKE WE’VE DONE.
>> Bret: THERE’S A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT POLLS NOWADAYS
AND WHICH ONES ARE GOOD AND
WHICH ONES ARE BAD.
THE GALLUP POLL HAS BEEN CITED
BY THIS PRESIDENT NUMEROUS TIMES
WHEN HIS APPROVAL WAS HIGH.
THIS GALA POLL JUST CAME OUT, HE
TAKES A TEN-POINT HIT FROM THE
BEGINNING OF MAY AND
DISAPPROVAL IS UP AND THEN ON
PARTY IDENTIFICATION,
DOWN 7 AMONG REPUBLICANS.
INDEPENDENCE, DOWN 7.
DEMOCRATS DOWN 9.
HAROLD, WERE YOU SEE THIS NOW AS
FAR AS THIS PRESIDENT AND WHAT
HE DOES OR DOESN’T HAVE TO DO TO
CHANGE HIS SITUATION.
>> CHARLIE LAID OUT VERY WELL AT
THE COUNTRY, PARTICULARLY
DEMOCRATS SHOULD DO WITH
MR. FLOYD’S BROTHERS TESTIMONY
WHICH I AGREE WITH CHARLIE WAS
ALL THE THINGS HE SAID PLUS RAW
AND COMPELLING, VERY CONSISTENT
WITH THE FLOYD’S FAMILIES EULOGY
OF THEIR BROTHER AND UNCLE AND
FATHER.
I WOULD HOPE THE PRESIDENT WOULD
LISTEN AS WELL.
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT SOME
SENIOR MEMBERS OF THE
PRESIDENT’S STAFF INCLUDING HIS
SON-IN-LAW WAS ON THE HILL
MEETING WITH SENATOR SCOTT AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS AT THE SAME
TIME TOUTING THAT HE IS OPPOSED
TO BANNING CHOKE HOLD AND
LIFTING THE LIMITED LIABILITY
PROTECTION THAT COPS ENJOY.
HE SHOULD FOLLOW MR. FLOYD’S
BROTHER’S RECOMMENDATION I THINK
WE COULD FIND AN EASY AND QUICK
AND POWERFULLY EFFECTIVE ANSWER
TO THE CHALLENGES THAT A LOT OF
AMERICANS ARE FACING.
WITH REGARD TO THE POLLING AND
LISTENING TO WHAT THE PRESIDENT
SAID IN THE MEETING WITH SOME
AFRICAN-AMERICAN LEADERS, WHAT’S
INTERESTING, COVID SHOWED THE
FRAGILITY THAT A LOT OF BLACK
AMERICAN HOUSEHOLDS FACED
PARTICULARLY WORKING BLACK
HOUSEHOLDS FACED IN THE KINDS OF
THINGS WE NEED TO BE THINKING
ABOUT, THE KINDS OF INVESTMENTS
WE NEED TO BE THINKING ABOUT AS
A NATION SO AS MUCH AS THE
PRESIDENT IS PROUD OF THE THINGS
HE’S DONE AND HE SHOULD BE,
COVID-19 HAS REVEALED TO US AS A
NATION THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT
PARTICULARLY AFRICAN-AMERICANS
AND BROWN AND BLACK COMMUNITIES
ARE FACING, INCLUDING THE FACT
THAT BLACK AND BROWN HOUSEHOLDS
FACED A HARSHER REALITY FROM
COVID THAN OTHER HOUSEHOLDS.
IN THE POLL NUMBERS, THEY ARE
REAL.
THE PRESIDENT COULD COME BACK.
THE MOST DISTURBING THING THAT I
SAW ON YOUR SHOW TONIGHT WAS THE
FAMILY IN NEW JERSEY, THE
BROTHERS THAT DECIDED TO REENACT
SOME EPISODE THAT THEY BELIEVED
HAPPENED IN MINNEAPOLIS WHICH WE
ALL SAW ON TAPE, AS IF THAT WAS
SOME WAY TO SAY TO THE COUNTRY
THIS IS THE RIGHT WAY TO GO.
ALTHOUGH THE PRESIDENT IS NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT THEY DID,
HE DOES HAVE SOME RESPONSIBILITY
TO DENOUNCE IT, SINCE THEY ALL
WERE WEARING TRUMP T-SHIRTS AND
TRUMP BANNERS AS THEY REENACTED.
>> Bret: MATT.
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
FACING THREE INTERLOCKING
CRISES.
THE CRISIS OF THE PANDEMIC, THE
CRISIS OF THE ECONOMY AND NOW
THE CRISIS OF THE SOCIAL UNREST
IN THE WAKE OF THE GEORGE FLOYD
KILLING.
THE PUBLIC HAS TURNED AGAINST
HIM ON TWO OF THOSE THREE, THE
PANDEMIC AND THE FLOYD KILLING
SO IT’S VERY IMPORTANT FOR HIM I
THINK TO RECOVER THE LOST GROUND
BY ENCOURAGING THE BIPARTISAN
EFFORTS OF SENATOR SCOTT TO WORK
OUT SOME SORT OF POLICE REFORM
BILL.
>> Bret: CHARLIE, DOES HE GIVE
A SPEECH ON THIS MOMENT, AS FAR
AS A RACE SPEECH?
>> I THINK YOU WILL AND I THINK
HE’LL TALK A LOT ABOUT A BETWEEN
NOW AND THE ELECTION AND I THINK
HE’S GOT A VERY STRONG POSITION
TO STICK UP FOR THE POLICE
BECAUSE THE MAJORITY OF POLICE
ARE VERY GOOD PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE VERY, VERY DIFFICULT
JOBS.
THE FACT, THE IDEA THAT YOU HAVE
AN ENTIRE POLITICAL PARTY
APPEARING TO RUN OFF WITH THIS
NOTION THAT POLICE DEPARTMENT
SHOULD BE BURNT DOWN OR SHUT
DOWN OR DEFUNDED OR WHATEVER,
THAT’S CRAZY.
IF DONALD TRUMP BETWEEN NOW AND